the Joe Rogan experience something's
happening now where French comics are
getting exposed for stealing American
comedy verbatim now and and and
translating to French like and there was
a video that came out today that showed
Dave Chappelle and then some french
comic ripping him off Jerry Seinfeld and
then some French comic Rick ripping him
up and actually popping them off with
the same hand motions the same doing his
accent French just doing exact in French
as if they were the only human beings
who spoke both English and French this
was something that we had heard about
forever from the Montreal Comedy
Festival oh really
yeah because the Montreal Comedy
Festival not the people that perform
there but we would perform in Montreal
and we would talk to guys who were
comics that's that spoke English and
French right
and a lot of the guys that spoke French
sometimes they would tell you they did
French shows yeah I go how was that like
that's weird like you do French shows
and English shows and they go it's
interesting but there's there's a bunch
of comics that are famous only in the
french-speaking world of touring comedy
and they just steal from American comics
and just say their stuff in French I go
no oh yeah it's blatant and there's
there's a handful of comedians that
we're making a living touring three
years just stealing everybody [ __ ] I
love having skills here I love how they
steal from the biggest guys with so
stupid yeah yeah I mean literally this
is okay wow they're getting a guy from
2004 so this is their guy this is like
hashtag me too that's hilarious look a
copy comic mix yeah 85 or 86 to 2005
well that's GAD do you know him yeah how
do you know he they call him the Jerry
Seinfeld of well of France well he took
that [ __ ] literally he's good he's good
friends with Jerry
yeah well stealing jerry [ __ ] man yeah
it's uh it's interesting and they're
using hashtag copy comic and hashtag
copy comic mix
this is like french-speaking comedians
who don't do this who like enough is
enough you [ __ ] and yeah they're mad
and they're coming out yeah maybe maybe
[Applause]